all right pretty boy where is it where's
what the secret bathroom sure it was
Beth and we're okay cap I'll be right
there
don't lie to us we've been watching you
11:18 a.m. Rosa told you to follow her
and you guys left together you returned
at 11:31 smelling of lavender and you've
been drinking chamomile tea all day long
and haven't been to the men's room once
since what do you choose I went to being
good detectives since it came to secret
bathrooms now I put the poisonous gas on
one of these balloons so if any of them
pops you may die
Oh April we would all die gases fill the
volume of whatever container they're in
school which one of my two favorite
pastimes shall I indulge in video games
or pornography that's it make a porn
video game a porn video game it can't be
done look Trey history's greatest
perverts of tribe Walt Disney Larry
Flynt the Japanese but they can't do it
because of the uncanny valley let me
show you something
check out this chart you see as
artificial representations of humans
become more and more realistic they
reach a point where they stopping and
deering and become creepy tell it to me
in Star Wars all right we like r2d2 and
c3po they're nice and up here we have a
real person like Han Solo he acts like
he doesn't care but he does but down
here we have a CGI stormtrooper or Tom
Hanks and the Polar Express I'm scared
get me out of it and that's the problem
you're in the valley now and it's
impossible to get out that's where
you're wrong I was born to design a
video game with characters get weird
with each other for golden points my
genius will not be denied I'm like
Mozart you're like that guy that was
always jealous
of Mozart Salieri no thank you already
ate
you will not deter me the world is gonna
remember the name tracy Jordan
[Music]
I've never seen you like this mr. Jordan
this project is consuming me no for the
first time in my life I know my purpose
I'm doing this for my children my genius
has come alive like toys when your back
is turned
I see the potential for Attica and
everything around me this Cup disabled
even you Kenneth well I am wearing a
cuff to trouser today Tracy what are you
doing they need you in wardrobe
I'm inventing a porn video game let this
man work no one is to disturb him don't
hold your breath P it can't be done
where else I would have solved it a long
time ago yeah I would have is that is he
finished
not yet but don't disturb him he can't
keep going like this he was up for six
hours straight
[Music]
if the genius so those threatening phone
calls were being made to tim orsk of tim
o's limos that's interesting does or
skies name keeps cropping up in this
case because he's the victim you know
he's the guy whose window was smashed
with this rock okay it's being extorted
for $10,000 sure but what about one from
him $10,000 I just said that we're
trying to figure out who's doing the
threatening wait I have a theory
I think limousine and magazine come from
the same word just focus I'm sorry for
snapping I interviewed horse horse there
it is again
oh you're useless you're completely
useless you're without a doubt the most
incompetent detectives I've ever seen
and I'm including that bomb-sniffing dog
who UPS all the bombs hey Boyle guess
who got the tim o's limos purple
jake is Jake back oh we did it's going
hedge guard signed confession you call
this useless you call this incompetent
you called us zeroes in the sack never
happened well someone said to me
listening no must have been my way how
did you solve the case we listen to
those voicemails again and noticed the
sound of parrots in the background got a
list of employees did door duty asking
neighbors if any of them kept pet birds
we finally found one who did and guess
what
the landscaping in front of his building
was covered with these same type of rock
that was thrown to the window I can't
believe it
what you don't think you can break one
watch I meant I can't believe you solved
the case well you're wrong on that too
oh I guess while you get your medicine
I'll just stroll through the candy I
won't get any you didn't buy two candies
too this counts as one
hello chief Hueber bird hey that's your
buddy Andy dwelled in such a shame oh no
did he fail his test it's weird he got a
hundred percent on his written test
first guy in history to do it but he
failed his personality examination he's
a sweet kid just doesn't have what it
takes to be a cop Oh too bad he's
certainly something of a genius we could
use his brains on the fourth official
police wristlock you can't hit me try
hit me we're here now try that it's the
same wristlock boom
too much pain you can't even hit me try
to hit me if I had my gun you wouldn't
try to hit me though is the thing
all right everybody nice self-awareness
except
hey stay where I am
alright guys after nine rounds let's
check the scores in first place with 9
points it's Aesop's foibles the
quarentine bears have 7 points
dunder-mifflin a-team has 4 points the
DM backup team has 3 points the
Einsteins have 8 points ladies gaga have
5 points so our best chance of hitting
our mark is now in the hands and brains
of Kevin Meredith Erin and Kelly do I
like these odds my answer is no means
the top 3 teams are gonna finish it off
in the speed round so let's get everyone
some bells in third place we have the
Einsteins oh yeah second place we have
the clearance eat bears and first place
is Aesop's foibles yeah but they're
gonna get clobbered bring it in when you
know at first question this man had a
fatwa declared on him
when Einstein what is it did my part
baby I'm just the pill girl hey sups
Salman Rushdie Salman Rushdie is correct
heading up to see sailors on a square
rigged ship the sail set furthest
forward is called what persisting dock
do not hit that Bell lying
Jim client jab is correct the Einsteins
[Applause]
according to a recent survey this is the
most common learning disability among
American adolescents boom
ADHD no that's correct for the Einsteins
[Applause]
sir
[Applause]
dial it back this is tail feathers final
round last two teams squaring off I hope
you're ready to play doctor our question
is about the health and the human body
oh come on the standard American analog
scale has a maximum capacity of what
weight 300 pounds point for the Einstein
here's your final question cinephiles
put on your memory brace this 2001
masterpiece from Zhu Parque Brenner
explores the intricate dynamics of a
family in disarray if you talk I do feel
a let's go Fonda Le Papillon yes I'm
sorry no over the Einsteins hey Jolie's
chosen Marion Cotillard exposes herself
a number of times in that film
the incidence wouldn't look I know it's
easy to say tonight was just a fluke and
maybe it was but here's a piece of
trivia a fluke is one of the most common
fish in the sea so if you go fishing for
a fluke chances are he just might catch
one
[Applause]
you